uh thank you jayakumar uh thanks to the
organizers for organizing a splendid
workshop
and inviting me here
and thanks to all of you who are
sticking around until the finishing line
so uh this is uh joint work uh
with my student uh shagnik mukhopaddha
tifr
okay so let's get started so i'm going
to talk about the message passing model
which was talked about in the morning
earlier
by david woodruff
so
here we have multiple parties
and they are connected by an underlying
graph
and the inputs are
in the hand so it's a number in the hand
model as opposed to number on the
forehead model
so the communication as david was
alluding to is point to point through
private channels
so messages are sent from
one node to the other node through a
dedicated channel which others cannot
access okay and you are charged
for
each each message sent
across all the edges
typically there would be k nodes in the
network which will have uh inputs and
there might be other nodes in the
network which do not have inputs but
they may facilitate in the computation
somehow and there's an underlying graph
g as i said
and
these nodes want to compute a function f
uh which depends on those uh k inputs x1
to xk
and the players or the nodes have
private randomness okay so this is the
model that
i'm generally interested in
and what we want to understand is the
total communication so the total
communication is the as i said the total
number of bits that flow out on all the
edges of the network
okay
and it should depend
as you might very well expect the total
communication should depend not only on
the function f but also on the
underlying graph g the topology of the
graph right
this area is
very little explored so there are lots
of open problems here
but
i will
hence what from now actually focus on a
very specific topology and at the very
end i will tell you uh how results
obtained on that topology could be
lifted to arbitrary topology
okay
so the topology that i would be
interested as david was is the star
topology it is also called the
coordinator model so here
there are k nodes
which are connected by a star so the
center the central guy here is the
coordinator who doesn't get any input
these are the nodes the leaves that get
input and they want to compute some
function
and as you can see from the topology
they basically cannot communicate
directly to each other they have to
always send their messages to the
coordinator who then directs it to the
to some other node
okay so as i said this is called the
coordinator model
and it turns out convenient
to
analyze this model it has been quite
extensively looked at in the literature
and one thing to notice is he also said
david that you know if you have an
arbitrary graph
these two models are about two log k
apart in terms of total cost right
because for example if this is the
complete graph which is
uh very well connected any message
that player 1 or sorry player 2 sends to
player 3 or between any two players can
be sent correspondingly via this path
right and so this player has to tell the
coordinator who this message is meant
for that takes log k bits
and instead of one hop there are two
hops
okay so it's two log k so if i prove
sufficiently strong lower bounds in this
model
it'll give me corresponding lower bounds
in the other model as well except with
this factor log k loss
okay
and as i said at the end we will see
another benefit of the star in with
respect to proving lower bounds for
general topology
okay i'll just mention that
okay so as a warm-up example
let us look at this equality function
very simple function
where the k nodes
get a case
n bit strings so each x is an n bit
string and all they want to
verify is if all the strings are the
same string or not
right
so the knife protocol is an nk bit
protocol where every player sends its
bits
to the coordinator and the coordinator
just outputs the answer
right
and as you might expect well for
equality in a deterministic protocol so
i was currently sorry i just forgot to
mention i am looking at the
deterministic setting in this warm-up
example i will come back to the
randomized
setting later
so in the deterministic two-party model
which is a very special case of this
star topology
equality cannot be done
any better than the knife protocol right
so you would expect that nk
is the best that the players can do
does is it true so here's a tempting way
to analyze this
um
so i'll use this notation pi for the
transcript of the protocol
okay
and
pi i
would refer to the transcript
uh as viewed on this link
okay
so what we might hope is the following
so
pi the length of pi is just the sum of
the lengths of each of these pi eyes
okay
and
let's have a cut which separates the
player let's say player two from the
rest of the graph
and then you might hope that well it now
boils down a two-party boils down to a
two-part equality problem between alice
and bob where alice simulates player two
bob simulates the rest of the
of the of the graph and don't we know
that pi 2 the length of pi 2 is omega n
because it's a two-part equality problem
and therefore
aren't we done because we just sum up
the thing
uh for each of these pi i's and we get
omega kn
so
do you spot a problem with this
argument
sorry it's not a two-part equation it's
a different relation
well if i for example
assume that well that's one problem
surely but if i assume that all the
players are getting the same input
well i guess the question is whether you
you reach the maximum everywhere at the
same time right that's right so
the point is well the way i stated it it
is the worst case cost right two-part
equality as worst case cause so it is
true that at some point uh
there will be about n bits flowing out
here but and n bits flowing out in each
of these links but they may not
necessarily happen for the same global
consistent input right
so there's a simple way to get around
this problem okay
and
the it turns out to analyze the
randomized model is much more convenient
when you have
these
these graphs because then these two
party cuts
can provide you
a very convenient way to analyze things
so what we will say is the following
let's choose a uniform let's choose the
following distribution
mu which is uniform over
you know all players getting the same n
bit string
okay
so
then if we look at the same cut again
it's not hard to see that this induces a
two-part equality problem where
the
the other players here on this side bob
site collapses to one in one node and
you have a two-part equality problem
where the distribution the underlying
distribution across this cut is the the
uniform distribution over x x right and
here we know in fact that not only is it
omega and the expected communication
cost is omega n over this distribution
okay and just now by linearity of
expectation we are done okay so it
becomes easier somehow in this model to
analyze the randomized in some sense
more convenient to analyze the
randomized cost of protocols whenever
you can
in fact i don't wouldn't have the time
but there are many interesting problems
for which which are randomized easy here
and it's hard to prove deterministic
lower bounds
okay
if you want to hear about this i can
tell you offline after the talk
ok so
as i said our focus would be on
randomized lower bound so basically
using that same idea or you know the the
the the basic idea that i just explained
by go looking at the expected cost
rather than the worst case cost uh
this philips verbenzang in 2012
they came up with a very elegant paper
and a technique called symmetrization
which they used to prove lower bounds
for various functions
the point was these functions were
although
not boolean okay they had multiple
output
and they could prove
various lower bounds for a bunch of
functions where
you know you looked at these functions
were that were of the type where you
were looking at either bitwise or
bitwise and or bitwise xor and so on
okay so
as i said these functions were
instead of being boolean they
did output n bits
and for each of these cases they could
show using this symmetrization idea that
the lower bound is omega nk
and later woodruff and zhang
in subsequent papers
built upon this idea and in fact they
proved lower bound as we saw
earlier today as well for boolean
functions which still match the which
match this omega nk
however
for simple boolean functions like let's
say set disjointness so here i'm talking
about the k party generalized joyness or
the generalized inner product okay these
are in set disjoint as an inner product
happen to be two cardinal functions for
two party uh complexity so there is a
natural k party generalization for these
two functions there were no lower
amounts known in fact it was not known
whether you can sort of reduce these
problems to their two-party analogues
via this cut technique
okay so it is still not known whether
you can do that
sorry
is there a new new paper
are you sure for general isn't it you
can't do it with a large enough problem
so i'm looking at the binary alphabet
so however in this uh uh
paper by braverman ellen osman
pitasi and vaikuntanathan in 2013
they showed a technique to prove omega
and k lower bounds for both set
disjointness and inner product it's the
boundary stated in terms of set
disjoints but it obviously gives you
lower bonds for inner product as well
and they use information theoretic
techniques
and this technique seems to sort of
fundamentally diff differ in the sense
that they have to analyze it as a true
k-party protocol rather than
reducing it to cuts
and looking at two-party protocols that
cross-cuts
okay and we are going to build upon this
technique here
so what's that disjointness
i mean this needs no introduction but
let me still go through quickly so you
have k players they get each a set
from some universe of size n and what
they have to find out is is there a
common element
in in for in all of their sets
okay so let's
look at the bits of set disjointness so
you have
basically you have this k player so i'll
view it as a k by n matrix because the
universe is of size n and what the
players are interested in doing is to
find out if there is a column
out of these n columns where you get all
ones
okay that said this join us
and in terms of
a formula for this it's not hard to see
that it's just an ore of ands
where the r has a fan in
n
and these each of these ands has fan in
k
okay
so
that's the formulas now
the function that we will look at
is
a natural generalization of set this
joyness so this is a depth two formula
it just is natural to consider now a
depth three formula
okay like
so that's a depth three formula which is
basically trying to compute the end of
uh
m many copies of this journal by the way
i should just mention here one thing
that
i think this was also done by david uh
although i'm calling it said
disjointness technically it's
non-disjointness okay but i will
continue to call it disjointness
okay so now i'm looking at this function
called tribes which is which outputs one
if and only if m
this uh distinct disjointness all output
one
okay so it becomes a depth three formula
instead of a depth formula
and again naively it seems that the best
thing that one can do
is to solve this individual disjoinness
m of them separately
okay
and this problem has been looked at in
the two-party context quite a bit
so the particular setting which makes it
interesting is when i have this fan in
m and this l about root n so remember m
times n is the total number of columns
the length of the input n and now let's
make m equals l equals root n now the
interesting thing to note is
with this setting
tribes uh has both
non-deterministic and core
non-deterministic root n bit protocol
which means
that if you use corruption bounds or
discrepancy bounds you're going to get
at best routine
in fact i think that was historically
the first
reason to look at tribes
in the context of communication
complexity so this paper by
jairam kumar and sivakumar in 2003
showed in fact for k equals 2 this knife
protocol does the best
and they used again information
theoretic techniques
okay and in 2009 uh heartwood cloud
paper implied which showed a strong
direct product theorem for said
disjointness which also implies a lower
bound for tribes
okay
so even in the two-player setting
information theoretic techniques become
very important for proving lower bounds
for tribes
so we can expect or it's very natural to
try to lift those information theoretic
techniques in the context of
the number in the hand model
multiparty so that's what we do so our
main result is to show
that uh tribes remains uh
very hard it's randomized the knife
protocol essentially is the best
protocol the randomized complexity of
tribes
uh
this m times l is n so it's n k
in the coordinator model
so the rest of the talk what i will do
is
i will first start with the main ideas
that went into the proof of set
disjointness
so one has to understand said you join
us well enough to talk about tribes so
i'll talk about said this journalist
and some of the ideas that come there
some problems that are that i want to
show you which basically uh tells us why
perhaps the cut technique doesn't quite
work
and then how this
paper of
bravermanital get around it
and then what what happens when you try
to extend that technique to tribes
the problems on the way around so i will
not go into any proofs i'll just give
you the ideas
okay
and
this uh the problems that i will
describe have already been observed
actually some of the problems were
already very nicely described in this
earlier paper of philips verbian and
zhang
i will follow uh
the way it has been described in braver
manita
and then
the the way around our solution to
tribes is basically going to be a
combination of the techniques coming
from this paper of bravermanital and
lifting the
uh gerar metal paper
to the
the level of multiple players
okay let's get started so there will be
there are going to be two key protocols
uh that one needs to take care of when
understanding said disjointers okay uh
they basically outline i mean they have
two very differing features and that
basically highlights that the problems
in analyzing said this joyness
in this in this particular model
so what are these two protocols one is
the very naive protocol where all
players send
each of these k players in one shot
simultaneously send their
entire input to the coordinator and the
coordinator gives the answer it's a very
obviously very dumb knife protocol
i'll call that protocol simultaneous
the since we're going to use information
theoretic techniques it's important to
understand from the point of view of
information theory what players are
learning and
who is learning what okay so in this
protocol observe
that the players obviously do not learn
anything because they've sent it all to
the coordinator but the coordinator
might learn a lot if the input has high
entropy
okay then the coordinator gets to learn
a lot
okay and let's now contrast it with the
other protocol
which is which i'll call the polling
protocol so here the coordinator is
going to pull uh individually each
players for each column
does he
see does this player have a zero or not
in that column so you go it takes turn
in pulling one player at a time so he
tries to find out from player one have
you got a zero in column i player one
perhaps says no then he goes to player
two
player two says no but then player three
says yes i've got a zero and so for this
column he does not need to pull the
others right because in this particular
column he knows it's this cannot be
responsible for intersection
okay so and then he repeats this for
each column so it's a very simple
protocol but
it's quite different in some sense from
the fir from the first protocol right
here
the coordinator may not learn a lot
from uh for each column in particular it
may not learn omega k bits for each
column okay because the things might
things might end very early
okay unless you design your inputs where
the input distribution very clear very
carefully but on the other hand
again if you have designed your input
distribution carefully
the
players who do not get polled
may learn from the fact that they did
not get pulled
one bit
each player who doesn't get pulled
learns on the average again if you
design your
distribution well he learns that well i
didn't get pulled so that means players
before me some player before me got us
got a zero so if the if the zero was
uniformly distributed then players in
the middle would learn about a bit their
uncertainty was half the half half in
terms of whether the zero occurred
before me or after me
okay and so each of those middle segment
players learn a lot
the other thing to observe is the
interesting thing is that
you know if you look at the
communication
rather than information
across a cut
since this is sort of varying across a
cut
not necessarily
one bit is flowing for each column in
other words there may not be a cut where
omega n bits of communication is
happening on the average somehow
you know
things are happening as expected
okay
so these are the two opposing and you
will see that in order to design this
distribution the right distribution
where
you either charge the coordinator or
charge the players
you have to design a distribution that
balances this both to sort of opposing
demands
okay and the information measure
therefore should look something like
this one part of it should account for
the fact of the players learning and the
other
part should account for the
uh coordinate is learning
okay
so this part is
to take into account the polling
protocol because here you expect if you
design your distribution well
that the players would learn a lot about
the other player's input and for this
part you need to design as i said a
distribution says that the
observer or the coordinator who has no
input learns a lot about the inputs
okay so how how would our distribution
go well from our first of all from our
two-party understanding of this
jointness
you know if you want to
eventually we want to say that now you
can't do anything better than basically
learning each column right so you have
to
have your distribution supported
entirely on the zeros
each of these and this is a this is a
standard thing that we do also in
two-party so that's
a no-brainer so you have to have
supported on zeros of ants okay so that
you get a
direct sum
and then as i said in order to beat the
polling protocol you need to hide your
zeros well
smoothly
okay
so here's how the polling protocol goes
perhaps
and
so you need to hide your zeros well so
that you know it probes deeply
and again for to beat the simultaneous
protocol you want your inputs to have
sufficiently large entropy omega n it
should have at least 10k bits of entropy
otherwise you can't hope to prove an
incubate doorbell right so for instance
if you were to design a distribution
which had exactly
in each column one zero uniformly hidden
that might be good for the for the
polling protocol but it's not good for
the other protocol because that only has
n log k bits of entropy
okay so the so the
uh the coordinator wouldn't learn much
for the simultaneous protocol so how do
we do that so this is we're going to uh
look at the distribution that
bravermanital came up
so the input distribution is going to be
the following
now
the coordinator
it's going to be a convex combination of
two distributions one accounting for the
polling protocol and the other
accounting for the
simultaneous protocol
so it will be switched and the switch
will be owned by the coordinator that it
would be convenient to think of it in
that way so there'd be
two auxiliary random variables
one i'll call zj and the other mj
j for the column so z
uh
zj indicates for column j where do you
hide the zero
okay
and so whatever the value of zj is in
that particular column
at zj you will always put a zero
whereas mj is a bernoulli random
variable it has two possible outputs a
or b
and
corresponding to a
you have the following distribution
where you have exactly one zero
okay and the 0 is where z j indicated it
to be
and then b
is well again you have 0 where z j
indicates
it to b and then the other bits are
completely chosen at random between 0 1.
so notice that this protocol b has very
uh sorry distribution b has high entropy
and distribution a does not have high
entropy but it hides zero
so roughly you would think that with
half half probability
you would
you do that for technical reasons it's
not exactly half hour but will pretend
as if it's half off okay for simplicity
okay and the information cost of a
protocol sorry there should not be a
function here just pi
is
so we're going to modify it slightly as
well
since we can without loss of generality
assume that the switches are owned by
the coordinator the coordinate does not
get any input but he gets this m and z
okay so this first part
uh basically uh
represents what player xi learns from
his local view of the transcript
about and this this this switch m and
this switch m
turns out to represent the knowledge of
the uh the
the inputs of the other players
okay
so this sums up the the
this is the cost of uh this is the
information that player xi learns
similarly this is the information
that the coordinator learns about excise
input
and we are going to sum it over all
players i i equals 1 to k
okay and
it's quite technical and involved but
bravermanital were able to show that
under this distribution and with this
notion of information cost
disjointness
admits a direct sum
okay and the cost of uh
computing one and
of fan in k is omega k so if you put
these two together you get your omega
and k information complexity cost
okay so let me quickly move to tribes
now what happens with tribes
well again the main point is how do you
what distribution should you put
so again the first the first part is
well ideally you would like to get the
direct sum for free but now at the
output you have an and gate
okay so you if you want your direct sum
it it has to be supported on the ones of
set disjointness
okay
now if let's look at this disjointness
so uh
now this
this instance each instances of
disjoiners have to output a one
and this is different from what we were
doing before right because
what we did before or for normal
two-party set disjointness you look at
the
distribution entirely supported on the
zeros of certain designers
okay so how do we do this well this is
an idea that appears in jks as well
is we choose a random
this fanning is l so we choose a random
variable a random wire here
and then we say that this particular
if wj points here we say that this
particular instance is going to output
one and the other instances will
continue to output zero so you're going
to hide the one okay that's that's a
very natural intuition because you still
want the protocol to search for this one
okay
and other inputs get assigned as before
so um
how much time
so i'll have to rush through this uh
so the so what's the uh
what's going to be our measure
of information cost just as before the
information cost measure remains
basically unchanged except not that we
condition on this extra variable w which
indicates for a particular disjointness
instance where do you hide the one okay
and
the first direct sum theorem basically
goes
goes through verbatim as in
bravermanital
okay
believe me it doesn't take uh
you you essentially follow your nose and
you you can prove this that the first
direct sum goes through
okay now what we want to do is
we are in this
problem problematic situation because
now we want to prove that
the disjointness the information cost of
disjointness also attributes a direct
sum
but before we had this zero distribution
on the zeros of said distance and now we
have the distribution of the ones of
designers so what we need to do is to
get a direct sum
for distribution supported on the ones
of citrus joiners
right and this is this is the crux of
the problem
okay and then here again this problem
was of course faced by in the two-party
context by
gyrometer
and we
take the q from there
okay so how do how how do you do this
so
imagine that
you have one on this particular wire
okay
and so of course what you want is to
embed a disjointness or and on a smaller
set of inputs somewhere here so given a
protocol for a larger instance of set
disjointness you want to solve set
disjointness over smaller instances
embedded as as many places as you want
and bring down the information cost
okay that's the that's the rough idea
right
so as soon as you have a one marked on a
wire
you see that you have to hide that one
because if you expose that one if you
embed your smaller set disjoint instance
in a way that exposes this one you
cannot carry forward the direct sum
argument
okay so what you do is you hide your one
you have to embed
you you the the place where you have a
one you have to have
you have to have it under your control
and you cannot use the other things so
that leaves only l minus one if the
fanning was l it leaves only l minus one
uh degrees of freedom so at best you can
hope for l minus one times something
right
and that times something um
sorry uh the right also you have to
modify this information cost because you
can't work with your normal information
cost measure before because you have to
constantly hide this
particular place which which which was
flagged for a one so you modify the
information cost this is basically
lifting the definition of the partial
this is called the partial information
cost this was introduced in the work of
jyramital and we
along with the new distribution here we
modified so that it just looks like that
and what we are able to prove then is
that this partial information cost
admits a direct sum but now you you get
l minus 1 times the partial information
cost not over one bit instances of n but
on two bit instances of disjointness
which was also similar in the case of
jks
but making this direct sum goes go
through
requires some interesting application of
the chain rule of information
which doesn't seem to appear in the
gyrometer work i won't be able to get
into that
okay and then the second thing is
to prove that just as before
that now that the under this new
distribution
the two-bit disjointness
has partial information cost omega k
okay so i'm running out of time let me
just quickly put things together so what
have we done so we have defined this
information cost and shown that
information cost of tribes admits a
direct sum this was not hard given the
work of bravo monetary
then
it's
we took ideas from jairam ital to show
that
to define a new measure called partial
information cost and then information
cost this is not again hard to see is at
least partial information cost
the main new ingredients are these two
where we show that the partial
information cost admits the direct sum
and the
in terms of the
two bit disjointness and then you show
that the partial information cost is
omega k bits
uh cost for two bit
okay
last thing i mean i promise that there
is
something to be had about general
topology by analyzing this star graph so
in some recent work with atri rudra what
we were able to show is that if you look
at a general graph
so completely arbitrary topology where
you have k terminals but the graph might
have other
non-terminals which have no
no inputs the cost for computing
disjointers or tribes is what you would
expect by the knife protocol to be which
is n times
the steiner tree cost the minimum
steiner tree cost of connecting these
terminals
okay so in fact what we show is
something very general which is
basically whenever you can prove a good
enough lower bound on the star topology
this lifts up to being the steiner tree
type cost in a gen for a general graph
okay so it's nothing special about
disjoiners or tribes
okay thanks for your attention
can you say a little bit about the
reduction to the two good just fitness
problems i'm not actually i don't
remember how they did here
so so so
you you would embed this i and j
of the two bit at random
this is roughly what they do
but what you have to do here in addition
is
so the coordinator will sample a few
things
so there are the switches m m z and w
so the coordinator
will also
look at a random set
uh of size
uh
something
okay so you look at a random subset of
one to n and for this random subset of
one swim of a certain size okay
i'm not telling you the details uh he
will sample this m z and w
for that random subset
okay and then transfer it to
the players
who will then using their private
randomness sample
uh
their inputs according to this mzw
and for the remaining he will sample the
whole inputs and transfer it
to the players
okay and if you analyze this protocol
and use the chain rule of information
you can show that this
we can talk about more details offline
thanks